[Music]
opening shot of a bustling school
courtyard in a show about a school
cliche I mean I'm as down for an
authority can't use technology joke is
the next guy which is not at all but
what exactly did he do to mess this up
he's nowhere near that thing when it
starts going haywire so it's either
possessed by the Dean ghosts of
Greendale past or a writer conveniently
put it in the script I'd love for it to
be the former but I'm guessing it's the
latter there's so much going on with
this random College crowd first there
are way too many students stopped and
intently listening to this non-mandatory
nonsense second why are they all spread
out pretty sure social distancing
guidelines were in effect ten years ago
and if you were really going to listen
to this wouldn't you get a little closer
speaking of which how could she possibly
be hearing anything from back there no
boombox booms its box with that much
boom and if it did what about this guy
he is far too close to the podium and
before you say that he may be hard of
hearing and wanted to be near the
speaker he has his headphones in but
then also when the angle changes he's no
longer creeping up on the stage so
clearly he's a wizard and poof the [ __ ]
out of there and this is clearly
Rapunzel you know what I bet this is
that magical College that the dead dad
from onward went to because friends that
is a centaur let me just draw the little
horsey legs and yep I knew it centaur
now you know that this is the most
interesting thing that will happen in
this episode you're welcome
remedial teens twenty-something dropout
middle-aged divorcee
why just exposition your characters
backstories with a conveniently specific
Dean speech when you can insult and
degrade them at the same time okay guys
keep talking don't move
don't move wait for it wait for it now
walk as if it's the natural time to
start walking like normal humans and not
because the camera is finally in
position holy crap I see your value now
viewing other people as objects to be
used for your own narcissistic personal
gain or as we've come to know it in 2020
introducing the show's main character
Jeff on silver John Oliver is not
educating me about the world's problems
and making me laugh at the same time in
this scene this poster of a lobster with
a tiny penis is never explained the
State Bar has suspended my license they
found out my college degree was less
than legitimate but you don't actually
have to have a college degree to
practice law sure it's only a few states
and there's an apprenticeship program
but if it's good enough for Abraham
Lincoln and Clarence Darrow then it's
good
for Jeff Winger and now they switch this
poster out because those are clearly the
hooves of a lamb being born breech and
it has a tiny penis what is going on I
thought you got a bachelor's from
Columbia and now I have to get one from
America yeah okay people don't remember
this level of detail about each other's
lives where are my people in Iran okay
I'm officially confused now they've put
a poster of two puppets coming out of a
black hole in the black hole has a tiny
penis
what I'm saying is this continuity
department has completely dropped the
ball on this absolutely meaningless
poster but how did you even know he was
back there taking a leak you never once
turned around before you got up to
reprimand him do you have like ESP or
something
also there are better ways to deter a
persistent pisser problem like a
motion-sensitive fan to blow the
pisser's piss onto their own clothing
woosh pisser pisses off after being
pissed off for being pissed on and if I
wanted to learn something I wouldn't
have come to Community College I
understand that not every community
college is great but a better priced
education to at least get your basics
out of the way can be a good option plus
most people aren't really sure what they
want to do with their career path and
getting affordable education can help
clear those questions up anyway the
whole premise of this show is built on
educational elitism and that's
definitely a sin these hotdogs are
clearly uncooked and raw doggin is a
surefire path to unexpected
complications also is Fletch so wealthy
he doesn't understand the basic idea of
a hot dog resting in a bun or how to
condiment correctly what's the tax
bracket for so elite that you can't even
figure out how to hot dog whoa
well the guy he was playing bejeweled on
his iPhone all class as a study group
iPhone sorry Britta for Jeff it must
constantly be June because it's always
blackberry season all right you want to
know my deal
come on writers give us an attractive
woman Lee that doesn't cave to a
handsome man's relentless [ __ ] e
advances
they've set her off a strong-willed and
hard to crack but after one barely
clever line she's starting to open up
ensure she sees through his [ __ ] and
sets him up later but I'm saying right
here at the start I would have rather
seen her reinforce her defenses because
winger is way creepy I got tear-gassed
and a world trade route the show's
credits say this was directed by the
Russo brothers but this mention of tear
gassing doesn't cut to a flashback
involving spandex outfits and quick
incoherent action moments so I'm
doubtful
you tell me the truth I will like you
you lied to me I will never talk to you
again except that in a few minutes when
you discover Jeff is absolutely lying to
you you overlook your rule to continue
the plot of the show so who's the liar
now liar put your contact info down
right there that's very cool I really
like this cool cool catchphrase glad it
will never become overplayed to the
point of parity and then co-opted by a
completely different sitcom in four
years discount like Breakfast Club huh
on one hand this is a clear-cut
violation of the explaining your
references ruling of 1823 but on the
other hand Abbott is pretty much a
character brilliantly invented by the
show to explain and meta contextualize
all the show's pop-culture references
but on the other other hand rules are
rules and that's why I have three hands
because my third hand was made for sinan
a little doozy in the chamber of things
get emotional wow I thought I was the
only one who excuses myself in
uncomfortable emotional moments to take
a stretch there's a game of poker where
is basically the physical embodiment of
being excellent at TV sense and now I
hate myself
at the start of this odd track meaning
all these people are running toward
their left then it's the camera angle
changes the runners are in the
background running the opposite
direction look at them go but suddenly
they're going the other direction anyway
running right but I invited more people
from Spanish class
is that cool inclusivity is fantastic
all for it but why were all of these
people just hanging out on campus how
did they all happen to have the free
time for this one block of time no one
left campus to go home for the day these
people stay in here until dark and I
just have a hard time believing they'd
hang out on campus past lunch through to
nightfall for the absolute fustercluck
that is about to happen she has a
cigarette in her hand with gesturing but
then doesn't have one when she turns in
that means she is a sigle litterer plus
her hair stays in those perfectly shaped
curls that you get with a flatiron
Britta is basically a conglomeration of
all the worst people ever they will be
unto turrible you said intolerable wrong
my name is Pierce Hawthorne and yes
what about Jeff's character makes us
think he would ever under any
circumstances crawl up onto a table to
accept a handshake the real Jeff would
greet that handshake by snarking it back
into oblivion
no dad what about you kid you keep
breaking the rule of the references but
I can't help but love you fine take a
sin off her Danny Pudi what can I say
since fall out all the time the world's
an imperfect place let us eat that is
not what they are called
I believe the agreed upon official
gender-neutral name is worshipping at
the burning bush I want to say something
sit down why are any of these people
hanging out this long for a Spanish
tutor go online and find a tutorial
group oh wait this is the year Susan
Boyle went viral and Kanye hacked
Taylor's VMA speech nothing else online
existed that year so I guess this is a
sin for Susan and Kanye you know what
makes humans different from other
animals feet no come on bears have feet
can you believe they got comic legend
Chevy Chase on this show he's gonna be
such a mentor and peacemaker behind the
scenes and assure his place on this show
for years to come Abed's a shaman you
asked him to pass the salt he gives you
a bowl of soup I know captain make a set
here is riffing and none of this means
anything but I just want to point out if
anyone gave me soup when I asked for
salt I would leave the table and never
return unless it was my own table and
then I'd leave the table turn off the
lights and watch them on my home
security system until they left arm the
security system and then block them on
Twitter because you know what soup is
better Joel McHale slips in a reference
to his previous gig where he made snarky
comments about clips from TV shows a
format that I'm sure I don't have to
tell you could never work I hereby
pronounce you a community rural
community mercial now it's like stripes
or meatballs I mean like Caddyshack or
SNL because peers might have some
thoughts about why there's an actor who
looks exactly like him in this world and
I'm happy to share them with anyone
whose time I've wasted more than they
wasted mine I'm gonna go ahead and skip
over the part where I point out all the
ways that Britain never wasted anyone's
time and go straight to the part where I
give this show all the sins for the
inevitable romance that is blossoming
like a corpse flower before me I haven't
taken the time to do any research of
course but I'm just gonna make the
assumption that yes they in this will
they won't they manipulative nightmare
scape and ask that Cine adds as many
senses they feel necessary just 50
Dean Hale Cine full of grace I guess
people be clowning me about this jacket
since I got here but if I take it off to
make them happy that just makes me weep
right my oldest Gambino seeks advice
from a random jerky just met because
that's what passes his character
development in this episode you just
wrinkle my brain man your brain was
already wrinkled learning new things
does not add more wrinkles that's an
urban legend pretty sure the wrinkles
are just a pruning effect from your
brain swimming and the brain fluid too
long really well it is your study group
all of these people want to learn
Spanish with a man they now know does
not speak any Spanish what is even
happening right now I'm sorry I called
you Michael Douglas and I see your value
now but but what has changed since you
all out at him as a lie or four minutes
ago what revelation have you all had
sitting on the steps listening to him
give inflated heartless advice nothing
has changed but TV shows got a TV show I
guess and that's one too many breakfast
club references sorry
you mess with the bull and you get the
sins in fact now you get two sins me
sending you and you sitting the floor or
something
nothing funny for some reason you all
want to wear the cinemasins pitch for EM
on your body so we slap that car on some
new merchant in the store posters
hoodies tanks socks below the YouTube
player or click the store link get
cinemasins calm you really think any of
these buns are gonna line up to get
filled by you first
jefe yeah hey man I guess Jeff my deal
is above all else honesty and love but
even more than that part is the honesty
in the house do you have something ball
up inside of you Oh Junior
you're born you know it you wouldn't be
here if there wasn't something missing
son of a [ __ ] I mean you look like
Elisabeth Shue maybe we can call a truce
yeah I can pick up this pencil tell you
it's name is Steve and go like this yo
I've been divorced seven times and
obviously there are plenty of shopping
days left until adulteries adulthood